how do you feel about
um artists saying that they're
blackballed nowadays
speaking of the baby
some of them are
but what does that mean
I think Blackboard is when you've pissed
a certain person off that has the
authority to make a call to stop your
emergence
I think it can stop your momentum for
sure but I think if you have real fans I
don't think but that's the problem most
people don't have real fans they have
fans of songs so when the sound dies out
so do they and they never build an
underbelly that's why I appreciate my
dog joining Lucas for taking me on this
tour because he's got those fans yes and
it's allowing me to convert them in
December fans yeah and they're learning
about me and that's why you got a guy
like Tori who's always had like that
super strong core following but Tori is
a different thing see but I'm saying
Tori can say you know I've been
blackballed from playlist which has
definitely happened but it doesn't
matter because he still had the
best-selling album of the week but he's
an anomaly because that motherfucker's
talented oh he's an alien everybody's
not that talented most people aren't as
talented everybody ain't got that talent
to be able to wiggle through that [ __ ]
so some people
it kind of forced to take a back seat
because they can't do some of them
things that he could do so he's he makes
timeless music consistently like he's an
anomaly he's an alien talented level
persifex for sure everybody ain't got
that that's real everybody ain't got
that and if you don't have that you're
trying to cut through and you didn't
piss the wrong people off it's going to
be tough yeah I understand like what
Russ was saying because Russ was like
you can't be blackballed if there's the
internet he's right but he's also that's
not true there's no context sometimes
too and I [ __ ] with Russ right no no
this doesn't say there's no context to
he's right but
that doesn't mean that somebody can't
stand in the way effects of opportunity
that will leave like like elevate your
whole entire [ __ ] like which is why he
is right and saying if you have a core
fan base you'll be fine nobody can
blackball you but you can if someone
doesn't put you on rap caviar on purpose
and I'm not saying that's ever happened
for sure because I want to put that on
Carl or anybody over there but if
someone doesn't put you on a playlist on
purpose because it's something you did
or you said or they don't like you
and it and that's the only reason they
didn't put you on it that playlist could
be the difference between an extra five
million streams and everybody's every
the way everybody built their career is
different so Russ had the ability to
build his career through SoundCloud and
touring and right building out and
making different type of records that
somebody like the baby wouldn't get off
if he was in that position right you
know what I mean and the baby also came
up with like a pretty solid core
Foundation no for sure what I'm just
saying it's going to be tougher for
somebody like the baby than it would be
for us right right and it's a whole
bunch of different reasons that go into
that but everybody's my whole point is
everybody's journey is different so you
just can't say that someone can't be
blackballed that's what I mean the
internet I think because I think I think
both sides are correct yeah because
there's context to both sides yeah it's
two sides of it you know what else is
important something you said earlier
when you return with your artist you're
managing yeah you kind of have to have
people like want you to win oh yeah you
like people kind of have like either
they have to like you or you got to be
Kanye West for sure for sure that's what
I'm saying Tori is an anomaly or you
gotta be NBA young boy where it's like
it doesn't say an anomaly and not yeah
there's nothing you can do
NBA young boy just dropped the album
what was it Friday I think he's put out
110 songs this year okay listen to this
right NBA young boy just put an album
out Friday yeah he just announced
another one today it's crazy
it's nothing you could do about it
Dwight is he helping keep the lights on
over there
he's contributing to those lights cardi
ain't dropped in a while [ __ ] shout out
to cardi because she been flaming them
verses oh my God that tomorrow two
versus crazy she killed it and she just
killed the Munch beat I I haven't I saw
she got on I didn't hear it though yeah
she's been killing verses yeah she's I'm
excited to hear some new Cardigans you
know what I say about cardi cardi
delivers records I don't know if she's
writing or not writing I don't give a
[ __ ] she's delivering them records
delivered so hard it doesn't matter she
doesn't she doesn't have to write if she
don't want to yeah and I'm sorry 100